donc aujourd'hui on va être plus sur la
base de but
il y aura moins la phase de transition
on sent vraiment dans la phase d'attaqué
pour se mettre en bonne position de tir
ils sont une vingtaine de filles et de
garçons âgés de 12 à 15 ans ils écoutent
attentivement les consignes du coach
il participe à la pièce jfb à l'académie
c'est pour eux l'occasion rêvée de
toucher du doigt leur entraînement de
haut niveau et de s'améliorer
ça pourra me permettre de me
perfectionner dans le jeu dans la
technique et surtout de pouvoir voir des
horizons ça m'apprend beaucoup de choses
c'est à dire comment qu'on l'a pondu le
ballon mais il faut d'iphones tout ça ça
ce sont des bases de en plus sur le
football
en rouge les éducateurs ils ont été
triés sur le volet ils sont pour la
plupart des cadres techniques dans leur
club respectif ils ont été formés
pendant plusieurs jours ils animeront
l'école de foot de la psg acadine on a
l'occasion de participer à un projet qui
est d'ordre mondial parce que la pj cas
d'émission plusieurs pays avec des
intervenants et des méthodes venant des
professionnels parce qu'on n'est pas
habitué à travailler dans ces conditions
là c'est beaucoup d'heures de travail
peut pas beaucoup les séances on discute
beaucoup on échange beaucoup et c'est
vrai que ça nous permet de sortir de
notre zone de confort parce que des fois
on pense qu'on est déjà arrivé mais en
fait non on voit contraint de haut
niveau donc c'est surtout ça que sa
porte
si l'ancien joueur professionnel garry
bocaly qui était à l'initiative de cette
école de football qui devrait ouvrir ses
portes en martinique d'ici septembre
c'est la première fois qu'on a un club
justement de professionnels qui vient
vraiment durablement qui souhaite en
tout cas à venir durablement sur les
antilles jusque là on est vraiment pas
sur le fait on ne propose que des choses
que des stages pendant les vacances là
on est vraiment une école de foot qui
sera l'année donc c'est vraiment de
proposer cette expérience unique
justement aux enfants et aux par le
président de la ligue de football voit
cette initiative de très bon oeil
nous sommes très intéressés par par deux
choses la première c'est
la volonté de faire des choses en
direction des tout petits
ce qu'on appelle le foot baby pour créer
des vocations créer de l'intéressement
auprès des parents auprès des
tout-petits
et puis évidemment tout ce qui concerne
la formation initiale et continue de nos
jeunes cadres techniques pour ces jeunes
là psg academy peut constituer un
tremplin vers le foot professionnel mais
il faudra travailler d'arrache-pied